you
that it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones video what I want to do today
is discuss the new series HBO is
currently working on about a year ago
HBO did announce they were starting to
work on five different shows that would
be based on George RR Martin's A Song of
Ice and Fire universe one of these shows
was said to take place during the Age of
Heroes and at the time George RR
Martin's said it wouldn't be called the
long night but as of right now it looks
like they will be calling this show
blood moon I actually really like that
name
since this new show is set during the
Age of Heroes it will be very different
from Game of Thrones this means there
will be no King's Landing no Iron Throne
and most likely no dragons as well there
is a social media account that has been
given some updates on the show it does
look like they are getting ready to
start filming any day one of these
photos even looks like they will be
filming at the Winterfell said which
does have me excited the very first
description we go to the show does give
us some hints about what we can expect
to see this series chronicles the worlds
descent from the golden age' heroes into
its darkest hour from the horrifying
secrets of Westeros is history to the
true origin of the White Walkers the
mysteries of the east to the Starks of
legend it's not the story we think we
know now one thing from that description
that always gets my attention is the
fact that it says we will learn the true
origin of the White Walkers I already
thought this was shown in Game of
Thrones during one of bran Starks
flashbacks in season six we were shown
how the night king was created and they
even said why they did this however
based on the description of this new
show it says this one will give us the
actual origin of the White Walkers I
also think that's why it says it's not
the story we think we know so what are
some of the things that we could see
from the new show well the Age of Heroes
lasted for thousands of years in which
kingdoms rose and fell noble houses were
founded in withered away and great deeds
were accomplished yet what we truly know
at those ancient days is hardly more
than what we know at the dawn age the
tales we have now are the work of
septons and meissner's writing thousands
of years after the fact since this show
is said to go from the golden age'
heroes into
darkest hour it sounds like we will see
the long night that's most likely why
george RR martin was originally calling
the show the long night Pierre is for
the winter when the snows fall a hundred
feet deep fear is for the long night
when the Sun hides for years and
children are born and live and die all
in darkness that is the time for fear my
little Lord when the White Walkers move
through the once like it says we will
see how the White Walkers were actually
created and we will see them ride down
on the winds of winter to invade
Westeros now during this time there is
no wall there is no Night's Watch and
there is no Winterfell so it will be
very interesting to see how they do
fight the White Walkers one of the few
stories we do have about the long night
is of a legendary figure known as the
last hero in the north they tell a Vala
hero who sought out the children of the
forest his companions abandoning him are
dying one by one as they faced ravenous
giants cold servants and the others
themselves alone he finally did reach
the children despite the efforts of the
White Walkers and all the tales agree
that this was the turning point thanks
to the children the first men of the
Nights Watch banded together and were
able to fight and win the battle for the
dawn the last battle that broke the
endless winter and sent the others flame
to the icy north now it says that they
were the first men of the Nights Watch
but technically the Nights Watch wasn't
created yet what I think happened was as
soon as the White Walkers fled back into
the north this is when they constructed
the wall then had those men guard the
wall to make sure the White Walkers
never came back that's when I think the
Nights Watch was actually founded so
although this isn't Game of Thrones it
will have several of the same
ingredients that made this show so great
we will basically get to see how all of
it started we have heard that the wall
was built by Brandon the Builder who
essentially founded House Stark and
built Winterfell
the legends also say Brandon had helped
from the Giants as well as the children
of the forest using their magic to keep
the White Walkers out I'm guessing it's
the same kind of magic we saw at 2/3 out
Ravens cave now I do wonder was that
really
how the wall was made or was that
actually made by the White Walkers of
themselves for some other reason that I
would like to know I would also be very
interested in getting to see how the
Nights Watch was actually created I have
always wondered who the first Lord
Commander the Nights Watch was maybe it
was even the last hero also who is the
last hero was the astark or someone else
now right after the long night ends is
when it is said that Brandon the Builder
made the crypts of Winterfell first then
the Winterfell Castle was slowly added
over time why did he build the crypts of
Winterfell who are those very old kings
of winter that are locked up in the
lowest and darkest levels there are many
references to those kings of winter
having eyes made of ice I've always had
a very good feeling that's where the
first night's king was buried and maybe
even the Nights Queen as well as the
other way walkers these are some of the
very interesting things we could see
from the new show we could finally get
the big reveal about how the Starks and
the White Walkers are actually related
this could really be shown if we get to
see the 13th floor command or the Nights
Watch as of right now this is the only
night's King we have heard about in the
books and this night's king was a stark
according to old Nan's bedtime story I
would love to see this story come to
life on the news show imagine if this
show started very similar to how Game of
Thrones started where we see a young man
from how stark want to become a member
of the Nights Watch very similar to Jon
Snow we can see this young man joined
the Nights Watch then rise up through
the ranks to go on and become the 13th
Lord Commander again very similar to Jon
Snow but then one day something begins
to appear out from behind the trees as
this stark is standing on top of the
wall he notices a woman whose skin is as
white as the moon and whose eyes are
like blue stars this start was not
afraid when he saw her in fact he even
chased her and eventually does bring her
back to the night for this is still very
similar to Jon Snow's story because he
too did fall in love with the woman from
beyond the wall only in this story this
woman just so happens to sound like a
female white Walker this is when the
Lord Commander who is a stark begins to
turn to the dark side they begin to
sleep together and when he gives her his
seed he is also giving her his soul
now imagine if we were following this
character for all of these years we
would like the character and we would
want to see the character succeed
especially being a member from House
Stark a house that most fans do like but
how would you begin to feel if he saw
this character begin to turn to the dark
side so dark that they even start
sleeping with a light Walker we have
never seen a female white Walker before
imagine how incredible that would be
just to see that I would also imagine
that this white Walker would have to be
gorgeous and maybe even charming in some
way but that's only until she turns this
Stark into the night's king then they
begin to have babies together and that's
when they start sacrificing these babies
to the other White Walkers that are
still beyond the wall how would you feel
about that stark then also how would you
feel about those White Walkers who you
would know had Starks blood it was very
different when we knew they were crest
our sons because no one like Craster not
to mention he was basically forcing his
daughters to have babies by him so it
wasn't really bothering anyone when the
White Walkers were killed but what if
you knew those White Walkers were coming
from a Stark who we had followed for
several seasons a character who he once
wanted to see when but now he's given
away his innocent children to become
White Walkers I think some of us would
feel slightly different when and if
those White Walkers eventually invaded
Westeros now according to legend the
stark in Winterfell eventually finds out
what his brother is up to at the Nights
Watch so he ends up joining forces with
the king-beyond-the-wall
and together they bring down the night's
king and the Nights Queen that could
also be a very interesting story to tell
because we would know both of those
characters and we would know both of
those characters were actually brothers
if they were able to tell the story
right this time we could actually have
some sort of an emotional connection to
the White Walkers in the night's king I
think that would make for a far more
interesting story than the one we got in
Game of Thrones now they never do say
what the stark in Winterfell does with
their bodies after they're killed
something tells me he had them locked up
down in the crypts of Winterfell and
that's why there are iron swords laying
across the laps of the statues it is
said that those iron swords help keep
the vengeful spirits locked within the
crypts
and we have been told that the White
Walkers do not like iron so when you
think about it
it does kind of make sense that
something a little more sinister is down
within the crypts of Winterfell I have
made some other videos about this before
where I show all the different
connections between the White Walkers
and House Stark if you are interested in
learning more about that then I will
leave that video linked down below I
think it's one of my best videos I ever
made if I do say so myself
anyways I only wanted to discuss some of
the things that we could see in the
upcoming show that has the working title
Blood Moon based on the description and
some of the early set photos that are
out right now we should find out a lot
more about how stark as well as the
White Walkers since it also says we will
find out some of Westeros is horrifying
secrets I am hoping one of those secrets
is about how the Starks are actually
related to the White Walkers some of the
articles I read said that we could see
this show as early as one year after
Game of Thrones is over so that's
actually not too far away
although Game of Thrones did not end the
way I was hoping I am still very excited
about this new show HBO is creating I
love the Song of Ice and Fire universe
therefore I will watch about anything
relating to the source material let me
know what you think leave me some of
your thoughts down below anyways I want
to thank everyone for watching the video
as well as everyone supporting the
channel I hope you all have a great day
I will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you